STORY ABOUT ASKING CHURCHES TO
TRACK THERE.
SEEN AND UNSEEN AS I HAD.
BUT FIRST, MY THOUGHTS ON
AMERICA AND SHUT DOWN.
DAY 51.
NOW, IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE THAT
THEY ARE ACTUALLY PEOPLE OUT
THERE WHO SEEM HAPPIER WHEN MOST
OF AMERICA IS INVINCIBLE.
AND CONVERSELY, THEIR MISERABLE
WHEN MOST OF YOU HAPPY.
BUT THAT SUMS UP THINGS ON THE
LEFT IN THE AGE OF TRAUMA, AND
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS
UNPRECEDENTED COVERT CRISIS.
NOW, WITH THE PANDEMIC, AS A
KIND OF COVER, THEY ARE KIND OF
EXCITED ABOUT RAMMING THROUGH
THIS NEW VISION FOR A NEW
AMERICA.
I’M NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT ONE
WHERE WE WASH HER HANDS AS OFTEN
AS WE SHOULD, OR COUGH INTO HER
ELBOWS.
THE GOAL HERE IS TO REMAKE
AMERICA INTO A PROGRESSIVE
SOCIETY, SUPPOSEDLY, A MORE
EQUITABLE SOCIETY.
>> WERE NOT GOING BACK TO
NORMAL.
IT’S BACK TO A NEW NORMAL.
>> WE MAY NEVER HAVE THE NORMAL
THAT WE HAD PRIOR TO COVID-19.
>> LET’S TAKE THIS EXPERIENCE,
AND REALLY LEARN HOW WE COULD DO
DIFFERENTLY, AND BETTER WITH OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM BECAUSE OF
TECHNOLOGY AND VIRTUAL EDUCATION
EDUCATION.
>> Laura: NOW, LET’S FACE IT.
AT THESE PEOPLE, A LOT OF THEM,
DIDN’T LIKE THE OLD TO NORMAL.
WHY?
BECAUSE IN THE OLD NORMAL THE
PEOPLE ELECTED DONALD TRUMP.
TODAY, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
PUBLISHED A SHOCKINGLY HONEST
ABOUT WHAT REALLY IRKS THE LEFT
ABOUT TRADITIONAL AMERICA.
ONE WORD, FREEDOM.
OPEN STATES, LOTS OF GUNS,
AMERICA IS PAYING A HEAVY PRICE
FOR FREEDOM.
AT THE TITLE READ.
AND IN PREDICTABLE FASHION,
COLUMNIST PRAISES EUROPE’S MORE
ENLIGHTENED APPROACH TO
LOCKDOWN, THEN COMPLAINS THAT
WE’RE JUST TOO FREE FOR OUR OWN
DARN GOOD.
AMERICANS WHO QUESTION MANDATES
ON MASK WEARING ARE STUPID,
SELFISH, AND DANGEROUS.
JUST LIKE THOSE GUN RIGHTS
ADVOCATES.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAYS "IN THIS
NARROW WORLD VIEW, FREEDOM HAS A
PRICE.
IT’S A PRICE THAT WILL BE
CALCULATED, AND THEN SET BY A
SELECT FEW.
THE REST OF US, NEARLY PAY IT."
WAIT, THEY ARE ACTUALLY
COMPLAINING ABOUT A SELECT FEW
SETTING THE RULES?
BUT ISN’T THIS HOW THE LEFT
PREFERS THAT?
THEY CERTAINLY DON’T PREFER
RULED BY THE PEOPLE.
PEOPLE WHO STILL BELIEVE IN
QUAINT THINGS LIKE THE FIRST AND
SECOND AMENDMENT.
THE LEFT PREFER RULE BY A FEW.
MAYBE IF YOU BILLIONAIRE
TECHNOCRATS, OR BY AN ELECTED
BUREAUCRAT.
AND BY LIBERAL GOVERNORS WHO
PROLONG THESE SHUTDOWNS WITHOUT
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AT ALL.
THE ENTIRE OF THE PEOPLE BY THE
PEOPLE FOR THE PEOPLE THING
HASN’T REALLY DELIVERED THAT
PROGRESSIVE UTOPIA THAT THE LEFT
SO DESPERATELY DESIRES.
BUT MAY BE, JUST MAYBE, THE
PANDEMIC WILL.
>> THERE IS A PRIMORDIAL
AMERICAN TRADITION GOING BACK TO
THE FOUNDERS OF BEING FREEDOM OF
DEATH, EVEN THOUGH WHERE A
COUNTRY FOUNDED ON SLAVERY AND,
WE ARE BLIND TO OTHER STATES OF
STRESS.
WHAT HAVE YOU.
>> Laura: LET THAT SINK IN.
WE ARE FREEDOM OBSESSED.
YES, I AM.
GUILTY AS CHARGED.
FREEDOM OBSESSED.
MOST PEOPLE WANT TO GO ON WITH
THEIR LIVES.
YOU GET THE SENSE, YOU CAN SEE
IT AROUND YOU.
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT WALKING OUT
THE DOOR EVERY DAY ENTAILS RISK.
SOMETIMES SERIOUS ONES.
THE OLD NORMAL, SO THEN, MEANS
LITTLE LEAGUE, HIGH SCHOOL
PROMS, GRADUATIONS, IT MEANS TO
CHURCH ON SUNDAY OR OTHER TYPES
OF WORSHIP.
WORK ON MONDAY.
IT MEANS DINNER WITH FRIENDS AND
FAMILY VACATIONS EVERY NOW AND
THEN.
OF COURSE, IT IS A HORRIBLE
TRAGEDY THAT SO MANY AMERICANS
HAD TO DIE BECAUSE OF THIS VIRUS
THAT STARTED IN CHINA, IT’S
AWFUL.
BUT IT WOULD BE AN EVEN WORSE
TRAGEDY IF WE LOST OUR COUNTRY
BECAUSE OF IT.
WE CAN NEVER BRING BACK THOSE
WE’VE LOST, BUT WE CAN TRY TO
REPAIR THE CULTURAL AND ECONOMIC
DAMAGE BEFORE IT’S TOO LATE.
THIS IS HOW PARENTS DESCRIBES
THE OLD NORMAL.
YOU KNOW, THAT NORMAL AT THE END
OF 2019 BEFORE THE CORONAVIRUS?
"HOUSEHOLDS ARE IN GOOD SHAPE.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS AT HALF-CENTURY
LOW.
WAGES HAVE BEEN INCREASING
FASTER THAN INFLATION, AND
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE REMAINS
NEAREST HIGH OF THE CYCLE."
THAT LIKELY HELPS THEM FEEL
PARTICULARLY JOLLY THIS HOLIDAY
SEASON, IT MAY OPEN THE WALLS TO
CELEBRATE.
IT SEEMS LIKE A LONG TIME AGO
NOW, DOESN’T?
RATHER THAN BEING HAPPY THAT
THEY WERE DOING SO WELL JUST A
FEW MONTHS BACK, THE AIRHEADS IN
THE LIBERAL MEDIA JUST BECAME
MORE BITTER, IT SEEMS.
AS DEMOCRATS BECAME MORE
COMMITTED TO IMPEACHING TRUMP AT
THE TIME AND THE AMERICAN LEFT
BECAME, FRANKLY, JUST MORE
UNHINGED.
AS MOST IN THE COUNTRY WERE
ENJOYING LIFE PRE PRECOVID-19.
THEY WERE ENGULFED IN ANGER AND
RESENTMENT.
AT THEIR FACES TOLD THE STORY.
PELOSI, SCHUMER, SCHIFF, WATERS,
AND DONE THERE WERE THE
TRUMPETING ANCHORS AND PUNDITS
PRETENDING TO BE JOURNALIST.
THEY ALL FELT DEJECTED AND
DEMORALIZED.
NICOLE WALLACE, DON LEMON, CHUCK
TODD, JAKE TAPPER.
BUT NOW THEY KIND OF SEE THEIR
OPENING.
REENERGIZED, REORGANIZED, MAY BE
REINVENTING.
>> SO WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ACTUALLY HELP
REAL PEOPLE, AND THAT GOES FOR
RENTERS, BUT IT ALSO GOES FOR
MOM-AND-POP LANDLORDS, YOU KNOW,
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS THAT WE
TALK ABOUT WHICH IS OUR FIRST
DEMAND, IS RENT CANCELLATION.
>> Laura: I MEAN, I’VE NEVER
SEEN HER HAPPIER.
SHE LOOKS LIKE, GLOWING.
BEFORE THEY ARGUED THAT TRUMP
WAS PUT IN’S PUPPET, NOW THEY
SAY THAT HE’S A MURDERER FOR NOT
BEING MORE LIKE POLLUTANT, AND
ORDERING THE NATION TO CLOSE.
REMEMBER, IN THEIR UTOPIA, YOU
MAY GET FREE BREAD AND MILK, BUT
YOU WON’T HAVE YOUR FREEDOM, MY
FRIENDS.
THEY WILL CALL THE SHOTS.
YOU WILL BE TRACED AND TRACKS,
NOT JUST FOR VIRUSES, BUT IN
EVERY ASPECT OF YOUR LIFE.
IF YOU DON’T BELIEVE ME?
LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT THE PLACE
THEY’RE PLACING FOR ITS
RESPONSIBLE RESPONSE TO THE
VIRUS, CHINA.
IT HAS BEGUN A BOLD MASS
EXPERIMENT IN USING DATA TO
REGULATE CITIZEN’S LIVES BY THEM
TO USE SOFTWARE ON THEIR
SMARTPHONES THAT DICTATES
WHETHER THEY SHOULD BE
QUARANTINED OR ALLOWED INTO
SUBWAYS, MALLS, OR OTHER PUBLIC
SPACES.
THIS IS ALL BEING DONE FOR YOUR
OWN GOOD, OF COURSE.
THAT’S WHAT THE LEFT WANTS YOU
TO THINK.
BUT IS THAT WHAT REALLY,
AMERICANS WANT?
THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS AT THE END